la imagen de Mariana bicher minski
tomada por periodistas de la agencia ap
le dio la vuelta al mundo y se convirtió
en una de las más grandes campañas de
desinformación por parte de Rusia la
imagen fue reposteada en diferentes
sitios web en blogs y también en chats
pro rusos en los que afirmaban que se
trataba de una puesta en escena que
Mariana no estaba embarazada y que todo
era parte de una excelente actuación por
lo que Mariana fue amenazada y criticada
la propia Mariana contó la versión de
los hechos el día que se le practicaría
una cesárea programada el hospital en el
que se encontraba fue alcanzado por un
ataque aéreo Ruso y tuvo que ser
evacuada en medio de los escombros días
después dio a luz en otro hospital la
información fue contrastada por la
redacción de los observadores